Comment faire décoller une fusée ?
Aujourd'hui j'explose le budget de l'émission et je construis une fusée pour faire un voyage dans l'espace.
La petite difficulté le faire avec un ballon
et du ruban adhésif.
Je n'ai jamais dit que c'était réalisable !
Pour faire notre fusée, nous allons avoir
besoin : d'un ballon, d'une pince à linge,
de paille, d'un bout de ficelle et de ruban adhésif.
La première étape consiste à gonfler un
ballon.
Et au lieu de le fermer avec un nœud comme
d'habitude on va le coincer avec une pince
à linge comme ceci pour éviter que l'air
ne s'échappe.
La deuxième étape consiste à passer la
ficelle dans un morceau de paille.
Voilà, puis scotcher la paille sur le ballon.
Puis fixer la ficelle sur un support.
Notre fusée est bientôt prête, ce qui nous
reste à faire est de relâcher le ballon
en enlevant la pince à linge comme ceci.
Qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé ?
L'air que l'on a introduit dans le ballon est sous pression.
En effet, enfermé dans le ballon, il exerce une force dans toutes les directions.
Quand nous relâchons le ballon en enlevant
la pince à linge, nous donnons une porte
de sortie à l'air qui va propulser le ballon
dans le sens contraire du flux d'air.
C'est le principe d'action réaction.
Dans les fusées, le moteur dit moteur à
réaction propulse un gaz vers le sol
lui permettant de décoller et d'être ensuite
propulsé dans le vide de l'espace.
Contrairement à notre ballon, le gaz qui
est propulsé par la fusée n'est pas de l'air
mais le plus souvent du propergol.
Merci d'avoir regardé cet épisode !
Je t'invite à refaire cette expérience chez toi
et te donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour répondre à une nouvelle question.